I just want to play fog yesterday I some
iris out I thought you talked about yet
seem haven't had it you know I didn't
have on stream my lobster yeah no sorry
not even honestly not tall and I've said
it before but it's like even the fact
that you're sort of continue with five
toes wet bullets as everyone else it's
the fact that you can hear the music in
the background and you've got that
massive axe well yeah the Baxters no I
never you hit people you pretty much
blow them up yeah it is God cod killa
thought someone would steal the kill
their I'm on it easier you don't have to
use the honey butter no I want to use
Lonnie bar jacker Omega buyers oh my god
chasing me oh my god good god ah markii
you just scared me oh my could chill
zone always yeah she made got noise
you'll see him I could see him leave me
being John run run run run but he's
coming this way he is cummins male worth
oh my husband have you scared I thought
something happened I'm gonna explain to
you how you become a kumar's basically
you know the few daughters a little blue
brief cases that you occasionally drop
when you die or when you kill someone
they may drop on you pack that up you
did either the few dollars and if you're
lucky I think we can you only get one
alaikum our spare game although what I'm
unsure completely and you should get
michael myers instead of like for
example you can get things like dal an
attack dog whatever you may get michael
myers and like like the phone okay i
came near 100 bullets are pleased me it
refuses to die you content you two mar
do with his axe
you
who try to think of a word to describe
best BAP carefully and organic was the
one who chose la grenouille although I'm
gonna die I'm present like we're not
we're not where is he one I tell you
there too but Harley oh they hate their
bushes I couldn't see them
but that's that's my loneliness Toronto
still have no idea what's going on the
swinger awake puddles of stuff I know
what's up my fing arms I've nonsense I'm
yeah there's like tunnels everywhere